thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
how are you guys doing nowadays in these
so-called manosphere space you have a
woman fact called Pearl Pearl Davis who
has a channel called just pearly things
which she criticizes women in
relationships and does all these kind of
things and recently on Twitter
why I saw some of her interactions
she was stepping out of line
misbehaving I have to say when she was
asking questions about the Prophet
Muhammad in a pejorative manner using
did he screw a nine-year-old and he date
this one and do that one
she did say this believe me let's
continue trust me she did say this screw
she used the word I believe but 100
believe me I promise you she said it
maybe she deleted it I promise you she
said it I know you're it's incredulous
she came out of her Lane
but then I had to put her back in the
lane no problem
and I think she regrets the situation
bro because it enraged many people and
why would she do that it's like shooting
her own first it made no sense but I
want to say something to Pearl
I want to say something to you the
problem is this
if you don't have a moral world view
which is well established
then the question will remain from once
you get your morality why does anyone
need to listen to any of your opinions
it's all subjective opinions anyway
as the Quran states
do they have false gods that legislate
for them that which God gave them no
authority to give to legislate in other
words morality on the Islamic Paradigm
comes from the all-knowing the all-wise
the all high the all-powerful Allah the
creator of the heavens and the Earth the
Wise One the knowledgeable one the one
who created me the one who created you
no one else can tell me what to do in an
absolute way
there is no obedience to the creation
in the Disobedience of the creator
that's Islam that is submission that is
the religion of Islam and she was asking
questions and she wants to do a panel
and these kinds of things
she invited me to the panel and stuff
I'm not interested I've done many
debates I've done the biggest debates
between Muslims and Christians in the in
the in terms of viewership in the modern
period for example the debate between me
and David wood in 2018 which has gone at
millions and millions of views across
different languages you can watch that
debate if you want to know what the
Muslim says and then see how the
Christian responds and what the
Christian says and what the most how the
Muslim responds on things I may add on
things pearly listen to me pearly are
you listening you have to listen to me
you have to listen to me on things which
have
creedal disproving implications now this
is an important key term the question
that you're bringing forward about the
marriages what's legitimate marriage and
what's not legitimate marriage the
prophet saws things it doesn't have
creedal disproving implications in the
sense that the answer to this question
and when the prophet saws got married to
whomever doesn't answer whether Islam is
true or not because you don't have an
objective morality that you can prove
outside of the Islamic framework John
Mackie writes a book called ethics in
fact and he says this himself as an
atheist and this is one of the
masterpieces the magnum opus of the
philosophical world in the western
tradition and at the end of that book he
himself says and I'm paraphrasing from
what I remember he says something to the
effect of that you can't really know
what objective morality is anyway unless
you have a list from God now we claim to
have that list from God
and our conception of God is Crystal
Clear which is why many people are
becoming Muslim because when they think
about Islam they think about one God not
a man with a date of birth who was a
child and came out of a womb and was in
the belly of a woman
yes this cannot be a god which is meant
to be the all-power of all creating this
is the thing
you have to ask yourself as a Christian
you say you're a Christian whether you
believe in this thing or not now go
ahead and watch those debates because
then you can see what the other side
says
you don't need to create a panel in your
own show to talk about religious matters
you can watch religious debates of which
there are many on the uh online space
that's the first thing
the second thing is because of this fact
whatever opinion you're gonna give
pearly avoid your respect to you right
although I have to say as caveat we
agree with some of the other opinions no
problem I'll say that openly agree with
some of your opinions but whatever
opinion you're going to give is going to
be a subjective value judgment once
again from Once you derive or
extrapolate your morality
where'd you get it from what Paradigm
are you speaking from are you speaking
from a wealth of great experience as a
woman in her
older a years and she's had such long
years of marriage you know you're a 26
year old volleyball player
I mean would you respect like what are
you going to bring to the table about
intersexual dynamics that the world
doesn't know and that hasn't experienced
in the first place that traditions
Traditions haven't spoken about
so the point is this is that if you want
to have credibility I'm being serious
here if you want to have credibility on
a topic like this which relates to the
family and Domesticity
of a woman or a man or whatever it may
be you need to have a paradigm which
you're operating from otherwise it's
just opinion
and yes you'll get somewhere with an
opinion you'll get
some views and some likes but at the end
of the day
it's not solid enough to live your life
with it
and one isn't complete and Integris
and
deriving of their self-worth through
likes and and shares and Views online
I've got it myself I've got many likes
many views many shares many subscribers
I can tell you I don't derive my
self-worth from this poly it's not the
thing that's made me feel very strong
and very feel anchored and very like a
sense of purpose of life I have a
purpose of life the thing that's given
me this purpose of life is the belief in
one God and the living by Islam I invite
you to Islam pearly because when you
become a Muslim then you can live by a
paradigm then you can be impressed with
a proper system that will facilitate for
you a proper relationship with God
I will tell you the proper relationship
that should be done in the family home
look into it watch the debates read the
Quran
and be respectful next time when you
speak to the Muslim people
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale